we're still looking through the
planetary part of community and other
reason why is because trigonometry is
one of the biggest components of what
you look at next year in year 11 and
continue the course and so that's why
there's so many if you remember those
licks that I was drawing across from the
current cost to your next year's course
one of the reasons why it really has to
be lions come out of it is because
there's so much five-foot-three stuff in
newton trigonometry okay so that's why
we're still there now today I'm gonna
show you a big crazy new idea okay it's
a big sort of new category you need to
get into your head and so for that
reason rather than jump in and just give
you the category good morning
rather than just jump in and give you
the category I want to give you first a
bit of justification for why I have new
categories good morning why introduce
new language when the language you've
been using is just fine right you'll see
that there are places we can go on to be
unlocked is the language that are pretty
powerful but first we need to experience
the difficulty in going without that
language so you've got your calculator
there now we're gonna do a bit of um
it's very collaborative work with the
board today I'm just looking at how many
people there are number we're going to
grab something in a second now we're
gonna ask all of you to help me good
morning
now even though your calculator there
okay I'm about to come around and give
you our number okay it's gonna be
another between dawn and ninety I'm
gonna give all of you a different one
okay and then once you have your number
it's gonna be one of these angles down
here you're going to pop it up on the
board at the corresponding value over
here so let me give you an example
remember we're reviewing right big back
to last Thursday
we looked at exact values we looked at
three particular sizes of angle three
sizes of angle now when you put in sine
or cause of hand you don't just get some
you know some decimal garbage at the end
you get something precise
okay often they had square root numbers
even does anyone remember what were the
three angles or is anyone remember one
of the angles yeah
thirty forty five six the very good okay
now remember I said four sine and cos
and ten we get these special values here
okay
just this morning to begin with we're
just going to think about sine so let's
think about side this side this and side
this will just review eight think back
do you remember what each of these are
equal to they're just nice easy
fractions what's the best one so on
hands up who remembers it I think it was
the first one huh very good
aha in fact you might remember this is
the first one I started with
we've popped it into our calculator and
then we made a triangle out of this that
had a one and a two and a root three
okay
which sort of gives you this side sixty
is the other ones anyone remember
someone else since anything yet what's
the science of sixty degrees it's got a
square root of it oh yeah Denisha very
good root three on - okay fantastic
I'll give you the last one for free
45-degree angle
you if you're in a right angle triangle
its isosceles right I saw sceles
so if you go back to that triangle this
is the rest year you were going to get
okay now we want to graph these guys
right it's great having these because
they're exact but exact values when
they're inserts are being harder to put
on here I have no square roots on any of
my axes okay so let's express each of
these as decimals each of them as
decimals right whatever - that's an easy
decimal that's 0.5 okay but on your
calculated now can you give me maybe two
decimal places we'll do it one / - can
someone calculate that for you what a
beginning zero point zero zero zero
seven zero seven so I guess that would
be zero seven one we're done okay each
right who's got root three on two so
long over three on two
sine sixty degrees that will give you
rid 302 or you just put route 302
directly in 0.87 okay can I get some
agreement on that who else ago same
value yeah okay excellent thank you
right now we're going to put these three
on here so you can see what I mean by
plotting this graph just like you've
plotted straight lines and parabolas or
molecular food okay so 30 degrees that's
down here okay 30 degrees and if I come
all the way up to you can see I've got
my increments measured in every tip that
our unit right so I'm gonna go 30
degrees up twos you're for fun should be
about there right do you see that okay
so I'm gonna place on here that's a
point right there that's on the graph of
putting it together all these values
right sine 45 that's at zero point seven
work so he's 45 between 40 and 50 so we
come all the way up to about there yeah
that's a bit above zero point seven so
just make sure I do that and my last one
was sixty degrees about 0.87 there's 60
do you print something new somewhere in
there okay now what we're going to do is
we're gonna street together a whole
bunch of dots you've all got a
calculator or it's a Neve one you can
borrow one I'm gonna give you all a
different angle and we're going to we're
gonna fill this thing in I want you to
come up as soon as you've got I'm gonna
give you an angle as soon as you punch
it into calculator and get a value out I
want you to come and grab a whiteboard
marker and put it on the board
okay ready here we go I gave you a
series of angles right and what you
provided me for a corresponding value of
x that was the angle of failure if you
like you gave me sine of that angle so
I've got you're used to UM you're used
to marking your vertical axis as Y and
there's no problem with that but our
particular Y in this case was sine of X
that's what you chucked into your
calculator okay now notice a couple of
things here number one I didn't give
anyone even that's where my axis starts
and ends I didn't give anyone zero
degrees or 90 degrees okay now think
about this carefully why do you think I
avoided those I
have to but I purposely avoided them any
suggestions as to why okay now I'm going
to get some just some very plain simple
answers well that's the first thing
there are answers for them okay but
secondly now I want you to think about
this really carefully right um
don't write down it's because it's
actually very tricky to word if I ask
you this question what is sine like
you've got an angle
you know what angles are what is sine
like you can pop it in your cap and it
gives you a number but what is that
number
well what's your answer be you're done a
favorite treat you can like at least I
couldn't ever in a while what is it how
would you define it I'll give you a clue
it's my clue any advance on that can we
give you another clue there's another
clue thank you one more you've seen this
down before right okay I'm going to stop
giving you clues now because the next
thing I'm gonna say is the answer right
what is sine sine is our society's a
ratio isn't it it's something over
something namely
opposite on hypotenuse right opposite on
hypotenuse it's a ratio it's it's a
comparison between how big this is
versus having this is right that's what
sign is okay in a right-angled triangle
that's why I have this 90 degrees here
okay you can't have a hypotenuse if you
don't have a right angle triangle okay
now I wonder if you can answer my
original question you really raised nine
degrees I left them off why because
there's a right angle there it's 90
degrees okay so the first thing is this
is a 90 degree angle over here right
because it's a right angle triangle so
if I just if I draw this on this 90
degree angle first and then I think
about the K what what my ex babe okay
there's a whole bunch of different sizes
of angles now if I throw in 90 degrees
there right let me draw my X now okay
there he is 90 degrees
now I don't care how long you make that
side you're not gonna get a triangle out
of this are you okay 90 degrees and 90
degrees can't coexist in the one
triangle because you've already hit the
angle song right you don't have any more
degrees left to make your last angle
okay can you see what I couldn't do zero
I got you right cuz if I said okay well
I'll make this angle right it's zero
degrees which is here's one side and
then here's the other side okay because
there's no is the distance between those
two sides that's why there's no angle
there okay
this is not a triangle I had on zero
degrees 90 degrees
they break our definition of sine okay
this is where signs started opposite my
imagination right but that's kind of
where it ends right I mean you've got a
whole bunch angles here dots it's not
too bad right let's just join this up by
the way I asked you to copy this down at
the beginning you can see there's a
rough shape to this right it's gonna
look something like this
I'll do my best something like that do
you see that even though you know we're
not all exact because I haven't given
you a green or anything like that you
can clearly see it's not a straight line
right it's definitely not a straight
line but at the same time it's I mean
it's going up it's going up all the way
and then up here kind of slows down do
you notice that the cave now we need a
better definition okay that's my secret
efficient okay better than opposite on
hypotenuse because yes this definition
won't cut it
as it turns out you can go reach for
your calculator and it's not too hard
you can probably guess before you put
sine sine zero go ahead put sine zero
you can guess what it's going to be
country's right it's gonna be zero and
you can guess what sine of 90 degrees is
when you have a look at this it's going
up to particularly these people who had
like high angles 82 84 85 88 all those
kinds of eagles you're going right up to
one okay and that's where it stops now
see how the lion goes clean this kind of
implies it should keep going it should
do something else right over in this
direction and over here as well
stop it should do something else but it
can't do anything else in this triangle
so we need a better definition